perché perché perché perché perché
perché perché io stavo vivendo la vita
facciamo quello che fanno tutti cerca di
sopravvivere lavora per portare a casa
una pagnotta hanno impegnato la mia
mente per ore e ore al giorno e poi vado
su internet e cosa scopro che questo
shark nardò è diventato super un bel
famosissimo tutti fanno la recensione
tutti e parlano su facebook tutti i link
nel trailer e mi dicevo o mouse quali e
tornadi ok come cavolo ha fatto però a
diventare così tanto famoso nonostante
ci siano altri film molto simili tipo
squali nella sabbia e squali octopus e
noi viviamo in un mondo dove esistono
veramente quelle cose lì e poi l'ho
visto wow sono cicatrici che non vanno
più via questo è vero detto che della
cyrus si è che pensavo fossero morti
tutti bruciati in un incendio è invece
sfornano ancora piccoli capolavori più o
meno ma non indiciamo oltre questo e
schalke nato il film inizia ventimiglia
fuori dalle coste del messico su un
piccolo peschereccio il capitano sta
parlando con il classico non capisco se
asiatico nodi affari importanti
commercio di squali sei quadri
[Risate]
ah ah ah ah ah ah se non si ha ancora
capito io sono il cattivo dei due alfa
emettere contrattano gentilmente sul
prezzo vengono interrotti da una
tempesta particolare
aiuto e siccome nessun capitano o quasi
abbandona la propria nave anche nei
momenti tragici
e per l'effetto ci potresti girare una
pubblicità della gillette ma spostiamoci
in spiaggia chiedendoci ma così servite
a quella sotto trama di un pescatore
vedo due possibilità a nulla ho
assolutamente ad un cazzo di nulla
scegliere con calma facciamo la
conoscenza di uno dei protagonisti steve
quello di beverly hills 90210
oh mio dio è proprio lui si è
complimenti per il decollo della
carriera lui è un amico che porca eva il
cantante di ramstein decidono di esser
fare un po nel bar poco distante che
troviamo altri due la gnocca e il signor
mcallister di mamma ho perso l'aereo
ubriaco fradicio al bancone non beva
troppo signor mcallister che poi finisce
come file ac piano con la pepsi tesoro
poi il dramma mentre il residuato di un
telefilm che mi ha fatto sempre tagliare
cerca di conquistare una ragazza colpi
di surf vengono attaccati da uno squalo
[Applauso]
e grado
scusate ma fate con calma non c'è
pericolo
ma sul bagnoasciuga arrivano gli squali
dove l'acqua arriva addirittura a 5
centimetri avete votato chi in ogni
cambio di inquadratura i colori sono
sempre diversi scuro chiaro viola blu
sembra il profilo instagram di una
quindicenne e basta tutti vivi a bere
birra come se non fosse accaduto nulla
che vuoi che siano 300 squali incazzati
neri o l'altra volta gli è morta la
famiglia hanno fatto un funerale a
bowling
ma c'è una cosa peggiore degli squali in
bassa risoluzione
una creatura talmente mistica che appare
soltanto nei film peggiori tara reid
nascondete i bambini qui interpreta l'ex
moglie del protagonista che la verde
della tempesta in arrivo però come
quando alle medie c'è il colloquio
genitori professori arrivano le botte
finalmente
[Applauso]
circa
o no effetti particellari ovunque
ti prego fallo ti prego
che bellezze e qui c'è una scena
veramente carina devo dire
[Musica]
dopo essere sopravvissuti ad un tutorial
di after effects decidono di andare a
recuperare l'orrore e sua figlia
passando per palesi immagini prese da
telegiornali ma dio santo
[Musica]
ecco prendete questa immagine e stampate
vela in testa perché la vedrete per tipo
mezz'ora di film loro che piacciono in
un'auto con sfondo bianco per la strada
rimangono bloccati in un ingorgo
intasato da uno yogurt magro quanto pare
posso essere sincero con voi a me le
scene nei film dove salvano gli animali
stanno veramente sul cazzo
no perché amo gli animali o un cane
anch'io ma perché io le vedo sempre una
cosa tipo milioni di persone sono morte
a causa di una tempesta
e vabbè vabbè andiamo a bere al bar ma
c'è un cane bloccato un'auto o mio dio
non possiamo la salute signora vado a
farsi sbudellare io devo salvare fuffi e
tra l'altro per salvarlo piccolo spoiler
cicr e paolo lui e per cazzo su
personaggi e stato utile come quelli che
si fanno i self icon millantato e io ne
so qualcosa non si tratta così signor
mcalister dovete danni rispetto dove mai
2496 schifoso verso te ne prendi si sa è
così
adesso abbiamo anche le guardie del
corpo jake link per stavolta è andata
bene
arrivano finalmente a casa della ex dove
ci sono problemi ben più gravi di squali
volanti il ragazzo della figlia e già
che ci siete potete anche discutere
delle future nozze affogavano tutti
quanti
eh sì succede quando c'è una tempesta
epocale fuori casa e mentre si allaga
tutto e combattono uno squalo
buttandogli addosso una libreria
perché usare il fucile che ha in mano
quando la pena ferisce più della spada
sparagli
o ce l'hai fatto complimenti alla
domanda chi è questo e dove fare i
provini di colorado ti potrebbe servire
chi manca ancora da salvare
ah sì il figlio quindi prendono l'auto
[Musica]
il cuso consona forza quella casa di
cracker al rosmarino prendono l'auto e
si dirigono verso l'area porto dove
lavora il figlio ma a metà strada
trovano uno scuolabus intrappolato ora
guardate bene quanto è alta l'acqua in
questa scena quanto 2 3 cm al massimo ma
a quanto pare no visto che le immagini
che fanno vedere solo queste uguale
proprio che sanno ma il 500 metri cubi
d'acqua di differenza vi santo la parte
dove salvano i bambini perché non
succede nulla di interessante e si
riprende il viaggio ma il pericolo è
sempre dietro l'angolo
o no come faremo a toglierlo forse con
questa mazza da baseball a te io un'idea
spalla i miodio donna non è un
fermacarte usano la macchina un guasto
strano non l'avrei mai detto
e siccome non c'è stata ancora nessuna
esclusione grazie si fermano in un
negozio per rifornirsi e parlare di cose
importantissime durante un apocalisse la
clessidra elevata mai tar quindi nel
loro dire mentale abbiamo uno tua figlia
amy a 2
ho visto come guardi mio padre 3 come
cazzo sopravviveremo l'umanità e buone
mani
decidono di rubare un hummer da un posto
che affitta auto per film chiamato al
side car punto com
c'è anche un bottone per il turno ma
pensa
e finalmente possiamo ammirare tutta la
sua bellezza
lo schalke nato
che sembra più interno di una
caffettiera però va bene arrivati
all'aeroporto trovano metto il figlio
del protagonista ma non possono più
andarsene perché il tornado si avvicina
mi sa che lo sperato qualcuno tutto è
distrutto tranne che per un
convenientissimo elicottero
perfettamente pulito ci sto credendo a
loro non basta solo scappare vogliono
anche distruggere il tornado con delle
bombe fans io avrei fatto lo stesso ma
non prima di un ultimo dialogo del cazzo
is my sun e aggiungiamo la lista anche
voi più bella a mio fratello che a me la
fossi copa de di spaccare la testa come
estintore è un ottimo padre
tutto è pronto per partire la gnocca e
figlio si involano buttano la bomba e
funziona
ed ha funzionato perché le leggi che
regolano l'universo non esistono
e allora approfittiamone sputtaniamo
brutto
ma mentre cercano di lanciare un'altra
bomba uno squalo si aggrappa
possiamo rivederlo
no perché è passata veloci non sono
sicuro di averla capita bene
che bella la vita a volte quella scena è
tutto ma non è finita
90210 vuole salvare tutti allora prende
l'auto la riempie di esplosivo e boom
che immagine poetica una pioggia di
squali
[Musica]
no
io sono morto e sto in paradiso stage e
la super anche quella di prima abbiamo
raggiunto nirva da illuminazione divina
dopo questo il resto è fuffa no
[Musica]
non ci voglio credere
e piccolo piccolo il mio cuore quasi si
ferma e piccolo
il picco è stato stratosferico
si no
voglio morire qui con quella scena è
stato etico
[Musica]
tutta
vai